wie intelligent seid ihr wirklich
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge doktor watson
letzte woche habe ich im video über
schwarm intelligenz gesprochen warum
sind manche tierarten schwarm tiere und
haben im schwarm andere eigenschaften
als auf sich alleine gestellt wird das
video noch nicht gesehen hat kann
einfach hier klicken ohne auf das kleine
logen oder in der video beschreibung ihr
werdet das schon irgendwo finden auf
jeden fall habe ich am ende des videos
ein experiment ausgerufen und das habe
nicht viel mehr leute mitgemacht als ich
erwartet habe
922 antworten auf das experiment selber
und über 1200 kommentare auf dem
eigentlichen video richtig geil
dankeschön für die große teilnahme bei
den ganzen diskussionen mit euch in den
kommentaren habe ich dann gemerkt wie
viel ich eigentlich noch zum experiment
sagen möchte und das ist wahrscheinlich
am sinnvollsten ist wenn ich daraus ein
eigenständiges videomacher anstatt das
irgendwo am ende noch dran zu klatschen
also jetzt habe ich zeit das ganze gut
zu erklären dass hier ist dieses
eigenständige video hier sind noch mal
die regeln für die leute sich das letzte
video nicht gesehen haben bzw einfach
als auffrischung für alle anderen ihr
solltet eine zahl zwischen 1 und 100 in
die kommentare posten
der durchschnitt aller antworten wird
mit zwei drittel multipliziert und diese
zahl die dabei herauskommt die solltet
ihr vorhersagen was sich leider
vergessen hatte zu erwähnen ist dass wir
nur mit ganzen zahlen arbeiten und alles
andere runden werden aber die meisten
von euch haben das sowieso schon gemacht
also das experiment ist recht bekannt
und besonders bei psychologen und in der
verhaltenstherapie beliebt ist zeigt das
problem des menschen auf mehrere
schritte im voraus zu denken
okay das wichtigste zum anfang die
spielregeln verstehen wenn jeder
einzelne zuschauer die größte zahl
getippt hätte also 100 dann wäre das
ergebnis 66 periode 6 also auf 167
andere antworten über 68 können demnach
allein schon durch den gegebenen
spielregeln nicht richtig sein
und wenn man davon ausgeht dass die
meisten zuschauer die spielregeln
verstanden haben
dann sollte einem auch klar sein dass
nicht jeder hunderten wird und das
richtige ergebnis wahrscheinlich weit
unter 50 liegen wird wenn jeder
zuschauer komplett zufällig getippt
hätte wäre der durchschnitt 50 das
richtige ergebnis wäre also 33 das ist
das beispiel das ich gegeben habe und
leider haben viele schon da mit dem
denken aufgehört und einfach 33
geschrieben
manche sind noch einen schritt weiter
gegangen und haben sich gedacht
wenn alle denken dass der durchschnitt
50 ist und deswegen 33 schreiben dann
muss ich ja zwei drittel unter diesen
leuten seien 33 mal zwei drittel ist 22
und mit jeweils 78 tipps waren das die
beiden beliebtesten antworten 22 und 33
hier seht ihr meine verteilung alle
antworten auf dem dritten platz der
beliebtesten antworten 42 die antwort
auf das leben das universum und alles
was ich ehrlich gesagt so lustig finde
daumen hoch an euch ansonsten findet man
die üblichen verdächtigen wenn menschen
sich eine zahl aus denken sollen zum
beispiel die zahlen der zehner reihe
aber eigentlich wird das spiel ja noch
nicht auch wenn ich bei 22 bin muss ich
auch damit rechnen dass die anderen
diesen schritt mit bedacht haben also
muss ich auch zwei drittel unter diesem
durchschnitt seien
das ist dann 15 und wenn ich da bin kann
ich eigentlich noch einen schritt weiter
gehen man kann ja nie wissen wie weit
die zuschauer mit denken man kann sich
also immer weiter gegenseitig
unterbieten 10 732 bis man schließlich
bei der 1 angekommen ist und die einst
wirklich eine interessante antwort denn
wenn alle zuschauer gemeinsam die 1
getippt hätten dann wäre das ergebnis
null komma periode 6 also aufgerundet
wieder eins und damit hätten alle
gewonnen die 1 ist die einzige antwort
mit dir alle gewinnen können sie ist der
global optimale zustand in dem jeder
zufrieden ist und seine antwort nicht
mehr ändern würde wenn alle anderen bei
der gleichen antwort bleiben in der
fachwelt nennt man diesen zustand auch
das nash gleichgewicht zurück geht der
begriff auf den mathematiker john f nash
junior der 1950 in einer arbeit diesen
zustand beschrieb und leider im mai 2015
verstorben ist der begriff ist sowohl
für die marktwirtschaft als auch für die
spiele theorie noch heute sehr wichtig
damit aber alle auf das ergebnis der
einkommen müssten alle zuschauer das
spiel tot ernst nehmen und sich so lange
gedanken darüber machen bis sie das
experiment vollständig verstanden haben
und da wir hier im internet sind ist das
natürlich nicht der fall wenn ihr also
zu diesem schluss gekommen seien dass
mit der einst alle gewinnen würden und
dann noch 1 getippt habt dann seid ihr
zwar relativ clever aber ihr habt großes
vertrauen in die anderen zuschauer und
deren intelligenz oder ihr habt nicht
weit genug gedacht denn so clever dass
das gleichgewicht als antwort auch ist
es ist nicht richtig
die leute die in die richtige richtung
geraten haben sind irgendwo zwischen 10
und 30
diese leute haben entweder von der 50
aus zwei drei schritte weit gedacht und
dann aufgehört oder sie haben das
experiment komplett verstanden sind dann
aber zu dem schluss gekommen dass es
immer ein paar leute geben wird die
irgendwas blödes typen werden und dass
das gleichgewicht hier nie zustande
kommen wird
wie auch immer euer gedankengang war
hier ist das ergebnis der
durchschnittswert aller kommentare ist
29,38 also abgerundet 29 und davon zwei
drittel sind 19 19 ist das richtige
ergebnis und das haben elf leute richtig
vorhergesagt aber kann man so wirklich
die intelligenz einer gruppe testen
nicht wirklich was ich mit diesem
experiment er getestet habe ist eure
fähigkeit voraus zu denken und bei euren
aktionen die massen mit in betracht zu
ziehen
viele menschen tun sich schwer mit genau
dieser art von aufgabe obwohl man in der
echten welt oft darauf trifft dann ist
es zum beispiel am besten sein haus zu
verkaufen
die logik würde sagen dann wenn es am
meisten käufer gibt die gegenseitig
konkurrieren können aber wenn man im
sommer 100 käufer auf 500 mögliche
käufer treffen lässt dann wäre es
leichter im winter zu verkaufen wo 20
käufer nur zwei häuser im angebot finden
bei vielen dingen im leben sollte man
darüber nachdenken was alle anderen
menschen machen
manchmal ist es eben sinnvoll genau
nicht so zu handeln wie die masse
handelt und daraufhin testet dieses
experiment die new york times hat
übrigens einmal genau diesen test
durchgeführt
mit über 60.000 teilnehmern kamen sie
interessanterweise auf exakt dasselbe
ergebnis 19
ihr könnt euch also in diesem sinne so
vorausdenken und kooperativ betrachten
wie new york times leser anders war das
bei der website play3 wo ich auch meine
inspiration her bekommen habe mit circa
5.000 teilnehmer kam die leser der
website auf einen wert von 15 und liegen
damit etwas besser im rennen
beide artikel verlinkt ich euch wie
immer unten in das video beschreibung
ich fand das experiment super spannend
und hoffe ich habe auch was dabei
gelernt vielleicht denkt er dann beim
nächsten mal etwas weiter im voraus oder
denkt auch darüber nach was andere
menschen machen werden hier kommen auf
jeden fall wie versprochen die elf
zuschauer die das richtige ergebnis
vorhergesagt haben
ss 19 04 von peschke anonymous
fragezeichen fragezeichen fragezeichen
games ego social lukas hohmann lubos lp
cayman lp fischer und basti shr ich
hoffe ich habe die richtig auf
wochen habe ich wahrscheinlich nicht ist
auch egal dass die mk ihr kennt euch
hier aus neue videos kommentare social
media alles mögliche bis zum nächsten
video etwas